on n'est pas des centaines de milliers
de personnes ont assisté aux funérailles
de la famille royale après le massacre
la nuit dernière à katmandou du roi et
de la reine a battu par le prince
héritier qui à peu près qui peu après a
retourné l'armé contre lui à l'origine
de ce carnage qui a touché au total 11
personnes
il n'y aurait qu'une simple querelle de
famille que l'on a d'abord attribuée à
tort à la guérilla maoïste qui cherche
depuis des années à renverser cette
monarchie constitutionnelle and co
signer hier encore le népal avait une
famille royale au grand complet
aujourd'hui le pays assister à ses
funérailles presque en totalité le roi
la reine deux de leurs enfants et une
cousine cinq dépouilles porté à travers
katmandou de vendée népal est atterré
par une hécatombe si soudaine une foule
agitée qui s'en est même pris au premier
ministre
il faut dire que l'événement a de quoi
dérouter car l'assassin présumé de la
royauté népalaises ne serait autre que
le prince héritier dipendra qui après
avoir tiré sur sa famille auraient
retourné la rencontre lui tout cela à
l'issue d'un dîner familial où le jeune
prince de 30 ans et son père s'opposer
au sujet d'un mariage forcé en réalité
les circonstances précises restent
mystérieuses et ce matin les habitants
de katmandou observait l'hôpital
militaire où est soigné le prince dans
un état désespéré pour tenter de
comprendre les ressorts de cette
tragédie familiale à peine croyable
d'autant que le prince a été nommé roi
ce matin mais puisque le roi traité en
soins intensifs physiquement empêché
d'assurer sa tâche son oncle est nommé
régent si la thèse de la querelle
familiale est confirmée c'est un bien
étrange destin que celui de ce roi
birendra couronné en 72 héritier d'un
régime autoritaire qui l'avait
transformé en monarchie
constitutionnelle mais son pays reste un
des plus pauvres du monde coincé entre
les géants indiens et chinois
il est engagé depuis cinq ans dans une
lutte contre une guérilla maoïste qui a
fait 1600 morts